raisa we have a picture of Joaquin
Phoenix as the Joker kind of I miss
Joaquin Phoenix as his character in The
Joker movie that's coming out and he
does end up being the Joker and as it
stands we just have a picture of a guys
Joaquin Phoenix playing a guy who will
eventually become the Joker when I saw
this like I woke up I checked the
internet this picture was out there I
was like not making a video on it what
is there to say it's a picture of a guy
and i'm maanna logged in my head for
about a half an hour about it know the
guy obviously have enough stalking about
something to make a video about so the
picture released is Joaquin Phoenix as a
character named Arthur Fleck I guess we
should Kevin Smith joke he's like so his
name is Affleck is that just a
coincidence are we allowed to believe in
that much of a coincidence I don't know
that's just kind of funny well you look
at the dude and we'll address it yeah he
totally looks like Prince valium from
Spaceballs got left at the altar went
into a downward spiral went into a
bender started beating dudes off behind
dumpsters became the Joker cuz he
snapped it's been said this is a
character study about a guy who's been
discarded by society it's a cautionary
tale which is why I'm looking forward to
this because I think that angle for a
Joker movies fascinating I think Joaquin
Phoenix can be great in that role if you
think his look is dumb if you're like I
would argue that hair is not completely
unlike Heath Ledger's Joker's hair these
Ledger's Joker has more texture wave to
it uses more product that's for sure
maybe he's born with it maybe it's
mabeline but the fact is Joaquin
Phoenix's character he's supposed to
look like a [ __ ] dumpster fire he's
supposed to look like [ __ ] you're not
supposed to be like that's such a cool
look I want to look like that guy I want
to have the look of the guy who's
apparently so down in the dumps he's
gonna snap in this cautionary tale
you're supposed to look at this dude and
be like I would I don't want any part of
that in that I like this picture I think
this picture does do that concept
justice you look at the Joker pictures
the reveal pictures and they'll
basically say what you're in for
you see the first picture of Heath
Ledger's Joker you see this this does
not say hey we're here for some laughs
we're here to see the fun Clown Prince
of Crime this says hey hi we're here for
some dark ass [ __ ] and that might
actually be the last thing you see
before lights go out before you die
Jared Leto's Joker we get the first
picture it's that and yes it says surge
energy drink had a kid and it is the
Joker and now Joaquin Phoenix joke
you're in for the poster child a guy
whose face has been so smash
into the mud by society he's an over 40
cautionary tale it could be a poster in
every high school that just reads go to
college kids or this could be you and I
didn't go to college I'm not saying it's
like a definite that if you don't go to
college you're gonna snap I'm just
saying when I was in high school I
remember high school teachers having
that mentality so I could just see that
being in high school I liked the fact
that he looks a little older I mean I'm
not calling Joaquin Phoenix old I'm just
saying when you think joke or you think
of you know 20 something year olds
playing them when it's the first Joker
movie when it's a Joker origin story I
like the fact that he looks like Arkham
City Joker he looks a bit whether he
looks older because that's the kind of
person it would take to snap like that
like this dude it's not like he's you
know a couple decades he's been alive
and shit's kind of down so he's snapping
he looks like a guy who for a couple
decades passed his 20s he still has his
nose in the [ __ ] and he's just like
[ __ ] I'm out why she plays a 24 year
old precautionary Taylor's don't smoke
but it just show the realistic character
film I hope this movie is I mean does
that not look like the photo on the news
like a mug shot or the pic they'll use
when they finally catch the guy it looks
like that photo that's Thank You
Catherine in other news today a suspect
in the string of murders that have been
plaguing the city has been arrested
today
he was found behind a dumpster blowing
another man dressed as a giant bat upon
his arrest he insisted quote it ain't
sexual you gotta make ends in this world
and this [ __ ] ain't free he looks like
the kind of person who would just snap
one day he looks like an investigation
discovery piece and for that I like what
this photo shows us there I guess there
was some footage that TMZ had if someone
on a cell phone or a camera and they're
they're basically filming a take of him
interacting with a clown I didn't watch
it or a take that might not even be the
take they use I would just rather see it
in context on screen so that's my take
my take is I like this pic looks like
that's the kind of guy who would snap
and kill people all right so Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker pic that's not actually
a Joker pic it's Arthur Fleck I guess
what do you think about this picture
what are your thoughts on it whatever
your thoughts comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]